you know don't you think it's chilling
out like as far as all that stuff
chilling out a little bit now that the
election's basically over
i know trump's still trying to hold on
to it but it's basically over
dude your guess is as good as mine dude
it's just like
right it's just like with just a virus
like look
i just want to ask a simple i i just
want simple answers and simple questions
i'm not a scientist i don't know [ __ ]
about [ __ ]
we're supposed to trust the government
we're supposed to trust the people in
power that they're making the right
choices for us
but when i hear the death rate is one
percent
yeah and and you want to lock down again
and and i go
i just go i just want someone to explain
it to me
yes i have scientists hit me up on my
podcast
like you know you buy the nights go okay
but
do we need to decimate the economy
and all the things that start children
no school
domestic violence so suicide alcoholism
right
all these things that have like i just
go can you explain to me do you
is it worth is there no risk reward in
terms of being like
okay we're going to open up but these
are the measures we're going to take
everyone still needs to wear a mask
we're going to do social discipline
we're going to do
whatever i mean like even all that we're
doing is
the the numbers keep rising but that the
death toll number
is low and but listen again we're not
saying that anybody should die we don't
want anything no yeah
no but but you can't you can't say a
corona death is more important than say
uh
than a smoking death or a cancer death
like where
how how are you gonna base this like at
what point
does the death rate cause us to lock
down yeah and corona to me doesn't make
sense
oh yeah i'm with you explain to me
there's never been a place because you
look at new york and what
uh como's doing there it's like he goes
yeah
we're gonna lock down if it if this
doesn't help i'm gonna shut down
restaurants and the restaurant owner's
like
we can't make you shut us down again
we're we're done done new york's
done so you gotta gauge off if you wanna
lock down for that reason
we're out man but this is exactly my
point that i'm trying to make is like
i'm not i'm not saying don't do it i'm
saying explain it to me
because that's and that's fair yeah
because that's kind of a sense of it
like if i'm just looking at it for
common sense i was you just look you
showed me numbers
you just said because people love to use
numbers yes they love to use numbers
sorry i got super excited because i'm
not i'm not i mean
yeah i just want a solid experiment but
if you but here's the thing if you go
just based off the numbers
you can't validate to me or vindicate
yourself for locking the economy down
this is that that's where it gets
so i just go okay i get this again i'm
not a scientist i don't understand this
and i'm claiming that i don't understand
but my little common sense knowledge
that i can feel just being like a
i don't know just trying to as an old
man i'm trying to be like all right so
at first
they didn't know what it was they didn't
understand it and they didn't want the
hospital system
to be overrun so they they said we gotta
lock down to make sure
we stop this thing okay until we figure
out so we figured out yeah all right
the hospitals have never been overrun no
no okay they're not overwhelmed now
in florida maybe now you there are some
hot spots apparently where they like you
know
but you know it doesn't like to me the
liberal media would be at the hospital
outside going it's pandemonium yeah
uh you know look at all the people that
are here that they're you don't see that
you don't you don't see that and maybe
it's out there i don't know i just don't
seem to see that
so you go so i go okay i understand why
we at first lockdown for this thing that
we don't understand
but don't we have a better understanding
of it now and it's like is there a risk
reward
so then you start to go why do we do
this and then i then i look at the
election and i go
trump got 71 million votes
five more million than last time listen
with the coronavirus
correct he would have won if it did he
would have demolished dominated hit him
dominated without it right dominated so
you just go
was this the reason is this the reason
why the one side is being strong
i don't like to politicizing of it i've
been talking about this yeah a long time
now that i just can't stand the
politicizing of it and like i said with
the numbers people use numbers now i am
not comparing these things
i talked again i talked about this on
riffing with griffin my podcast
check it out yeah i don't have the
following that this one does uh you know
yeah it's fine i'm not jealous about it
but i was just saying when you're gonna
compare
numbers yeah yeah and and the way
they're using these numbers
they got the death toll on cnn it's
always showing it's back now once the
election's over now it's back
so before it wasn't on there what did
you hear about nobody but then
so like they show these numbers and they
constantly have the numbers going right
and so coronavirus falls under now
preventable deaths
because you know you're getting it
because maybe you weren't safe or you
didn't you know
it's going to go under preventable
deaths so i looked up preventable deaths
all right mm-hmm do you know that over
000 to 400 000 people die
every year from medical mistakes
male practitioner yeah yeah like just
they just they just yeah that's just and
it's part of life okay yeah
so we never hear about that number we
don't use that number
over four hundred thousand people die
from tobacco-related
problems four hundred thousand four
hundred thousand die
now this is a preventable death people
smoke and they die
and what i'm saying is you know
we're not using so we're talking about a
million people a year
die because there's other ones too
preventable so many people 7 500 a day
people die every every year in like a
million people
from some sort of preventable death and
like
you know we're not using those numbers
the way we're using these coronavirus
numbers
it's political right you know and yeah
there are people out there like you know
there are a lot of people that feel like
we should get rid of tobacco uh you know
it causes so much like
you can just like so but it's their
choice and that's the same thing with
corona like
let it a lot of it let it be their
choice like i look at the comedy shows
like when you do a commercial i don't
know if you've been on the road at all
no i haven't but like you stand up live
every single person that walks through
that door they're taking their
temperatures
they're six foot apart they're making
sure that they're following the right
procedures
you know and it's like if you do have
symptoms don't go hanging out with your
grandma
like these are smart people they're what
the [ __ ] we need to be protected from
ourselves
you know and that's my only to what
exactly that's the only way i push back
on that is that to what
to what extent that well i know this is
what i this is what i'm
just getting at it's like again i'm not
comparing those things i was saying
yeah they're not the same as coronavide
at all what i'm saying is like
our reaction and response to them
are seem to be different so like if you
know
if for some reason now tobacco was going
to be some political point
then all of a sudden is that going to be
on cnn because i think it should be
it would be my my point is i think it
should be it would be if it would be
political yeah that's not i think it
should be like they should be talking
about that nausea and we're going to
talk about
coronavirus like let's stop people from
smoking let's stop giving people cancer
what i'm saying is like let's use death
numbers for everything
if that's what we're going to do that's
what we're going to do so we're going to
do that if that's the measure you want
to go with to tell us to lock down then
we gotta do that for everything yeah
let's talk about cigarettes
get rid of liquor get rid of painkillers
opiates we'll talk about opiates
if anything let's go all the way let's
make it like
like like look how oregon said okay
we're not we're going to decriminalize
like major drugs so my thing is like
they need to decriminalize in the whole
united states where you could grow these
drugs
like we should be making opium right
here in the united states yeah
okay let's let's just have a poppy
fields and you also cut out the legs of
the cartel and all the people that
murdered there
which are human lives so it's like it
goes down this weird road
yeah it's like so those lives not as
important or the nba it's like all right
well you guys do business with china
and then they're taking away the civil
liberties of hong kong so
those are those hong kong people are
those are [ __ ] humans
they're concentration camps do they not
count well what you're talking about
right now
is my problem with this whole thing
where we're talking about these numbers
and we're talking about the way you use
death
the problem is no one is making money
off of people having corona yet
okay they're making so that's why it's
hospitals are making off corona death
but they still are they but now they
they were yeah 15 grand a person
but now oh yes they were look it up doug
yeah but but now
you're a fat champion by the way
but now the cdc took that off so now you
can't so if a person comes in let's say
come in with stage four
cancer lung cancer and in the hospital
you you got
coven and you pass away now they can no
longer
say you died a covet they have to say he
died if that's not
and also what i'm talking about what are
you talking about no no that's
you know what you're talking about
service that sounds like a lot of money
to people but that's not a lot
you're talking about a hospital that
that needs money
that's not a lot of money it's not [ __ ]
i'm talking about
what we said about the nba like the nba
billions from china is this we we're
talking about
a billion dollars worth of like like the
nba
went back to work because they needed to
get that tv ready
so they're like okay let's make this
happen we're going to do it baseball
went back to work
we're talking about money like you know
i just saw today that the
disney people are upset at the governor
of california because he wouldn't let
them open up correct theme parks right
and i'm thinking to myself wow i'm
actually glad that that happened because
that would have pissed me off
i mean [ __ ] can go to uh
disneyland but they can't go to the
comedy store and watch shows
you know so get out of here so then
that's me makes me feel like do you
really care about public safety
or all you care about is your agenda
you're making money
so to me like money is the issue so once
like now
when this vaccine comes out yeah
and whatever billionaire pharmacy
company is going to come out with that
i think this coronavirus stuff is going
to change what do you mean and it's just
going to be a part of life
it's gonna be like this blue it's gonna
be there's gonna be there's gonna be
covet
cold and flu yeah tylenol go to cvs get
you a little vacation
like the the these are something we deal
with but there's vaccines yeah it's
gonna be something
[ __ ] you know but to me i feel like that
and i could be wrong and
i and i you know again i'm not a
scientist i'm not trying i'm just
talking about
it don't make sense to me why we're
still closed down you know what's weird
to me is so and i'm sure i don't see
comments or emails with that
but you'll even get hate for saying that
no no this is like that's what's weird
that means it's like
dude they attack you
do you understand what's happening in
the world okay hey hey we can't have a
conversation
i can't ask the question yeah that like
you know
why are we decimating
the world's economy for a one percent
death rate
uh that's my question is that a fair
question that's fair yeah that's fair
but it's winning
it's weird they get upset if you even
ask that but i mean like i was liking a
friend the other day and they were upset
with my stance on coroner politics
and i said i i just know from from my
perspective my
i got it my wife got it my kids got it
my mother-in-law father-in-law i have
several friends who have got it
everyone's fine
numbers it was fine some people were
sicker than others but everyone was fine
so i was like what do you that's my
perspective i had it
yeah so that's all i i know personally
what happened around in my circle
yeah it's just like when it's just like
when so trump got it right
and i thought that that was a i said
this is going to be terrible
because there's only one of two there's
two scenarios
he either needed to get it and get super
sick
okay like i mean like there it's death
watch you know yes
they're outside the white house with
having vigils
and then he comes out of it and he comes
out of it like energized he's like you
know guys
i really you know we got to do something
about this but i said
what's really going to happen is in four
days
he's going to walk out of the hospital
like superman look at me
yeah yeah that's what he did i'm
tremendous
full of energy you know you know that's
why i just go and that's not a good look
and these smug
[ __ ] on cnn and all these uh you know
they're like
news they were like well he got it like
as if like
i told you it's like no man this ain't
good
because he's gonna get over it and then
he's gonna he's gonna be like why are we
trying to
talk [ __ ] yeah yeah he's gonna talk
because i even have friends of mine i'm
not even gonna say the comics names like
i
hit him up and he's like no man he's
dead he's he's a fat
overweight he's not gonna make it and
i'm like
he's gonna be fine the the real the real
outliers when chris christie got it you
ever seen chris christie
no no he got it i went if that
[ __ ] doesn't die
we should never close down the
government did he die [ __ ]
no no i don't know he was in the
hospital for like six days
and he's just oh get away which is
terrible
show him the picture still on the first
pitch if this [ __ ] survives it
everybody good look at this dude chris
christie throwing it
yes oh [ __ ] look at which one this one
yeah that one
that guy got photoshopped you know who
chris christie is
i know i mean i didn't know
throwing several pitches got backs on
now right
look at this dude
was he playing like a celebrity game or
something no yeah he got a [ __ ]
no i just don't like all these chicks
who probably got a dirty wipe you know
i was thinking where's the guy song
though bro
we need an anthem now that our body is
worthy of a song
yeah no yes john except our wallet don't
know what i want to hear about the
biggest
because there were too many chicks on
the internet that i was just like and
like a lot of comedians too like i'm
like
i don't want to think about your
whopping no hell no no you're
not this it's like to me it's like
coachella
uh-huh a certain age you shouldn't be
there coachella yeah
i get annoyed every time coachella comes
around yeah every uh every year there's
burning man for you old [ __ ]
yeah yeah
yeah that's a weird one too
oh
you're over 35. yeah why are you at
coachella why are you there so that's
what i'm saying you're over 35 like this
is like
whop is for young people yeah young
people stuff i hear what you say by far
young people
you're you're i feel like like stage
coaches for the older
what's stage code it's like that's the
country it's country it's a little older
it's older white like you know yeah yeah
anyways
not to like we got off track but anyway
i like talking about it though
i'm glad you all i'm saying is uh
can we just have a conversation like i i
love when people people hit me up you
know i really i've had scientists hit me
up
yeah podcast i mean i was upset about
your taking and they hit me up with like
these are the facts i go but you know
scientists are supposed to
they they oftentimes are very glass half
empty because that's their their that's
the
they're looking for the worst case
scenario yeah that's all they look at
yeah that's all they look at it's like
but we are really at a crossroads it
really is something that you go
you have to weigh the pros and cons you
know kids aren't going to school
uh you know all like we said like
suicide suicide suicide's up 140
everything all this stuff is up and you
go and we have to ask ourselves in the
end like
is this worth it now if the science part
of it they're saying is yes it is
they think okay so all right this is my
point
if they're saying it is this is very
serious
then you go well is that supported by
the numbers
and if they say yes and show in numbers
and cool i'll shut the [ __ ] up
well but i just go like i'm not saying
i'm cool with 200 000 people dying out
of 350 million
you know i'm not saying no but i'm not
cool with any of them i'm not cool with
any of it but i just but
you make it make sense weird this is the
weird awkward
question that you have to talk about
yeah make it make sense
make it make sense to me that's all i'm
saying make it make sense
and they don't in it and it's and i and
i can't be the only person even people
watching this right now
even you angry like like you won your
guy
won yeah so now what what are you going
to be mad about corona
yeah like you know well let's bring back
corona yeah
dude it immediately came back it was a
report today that trump secret service
130 of the the guys got corona 100 dirty
130. i looked at that backtrack
franchise google that should change
that'd be a big secret service my other
problem is too is like that people
want to argue and talk about it and oh i
really admit i always say i don't know
about this i don't understand that's why
you have a question
that's why i have questions right but
the other sometimes people on the other
side
they want to come at you and they don't
have any facts like if you're
just mad like if you have to google the
[ __ ] you say after
thank you [ __ ] the f yeah
100 you know what we're saying like i
thought it was weird too
that you know the left the blue was
all upset about the rally trump rallies
no math
how dare you do this celebration and
then buy them one and they're all
yeah yeah
all in their cars what happened huh
now the corona that's all you hear on
the news now it's like corona corona oh
it came back yeah
came back yes well i mean it's just like
i don't watch the news they have nothing
they have no other angle though they
need ratings and
they need to put fear into what are they
going to do so what are they going to do
well what's late night going to do yeah
they're all like the head late night
writer i think
for uh fallon or kim will quit he's like
i can't ride another trump
i'm done i'm out that she's been there
forever okay i'm
out wait because she because trump
didn't win or i just think she was over
before yeah
like every day writing some really
unfunny trump sketches like at the
certain point you go
are we beating the dead every night
every day like trevor noah it's like
dude everything
like i know you're quarantined in your
house you're doing the comedy central
from there but
the only narrative is anti-trump and
trump [ __ ]
like what do you do now yeah yeah and
time to get creative
trying to get correct that's another
polarizing thing too it's like i
you know if you're blue you know and i
and i
i vote i lean more left when i vote you
know i voted for biden just because i
feel like the
country's too divided so i don't i don't
think that's a sign of bad leadership
you know so you voted based off
leadership yeah i just both placed up
you know but like
71 people voted for this guy uh 26
percent
i don't know if it was 26 percent
increase in black latinos
that kind of stuff you just go so then
you have one side who was like
you're dumb you know he's a racist he
why would you vote for this guy
it's like so we can't there's no
discussion so you can't have a talk you
can't be like
so these people that voted for trump
they're all misguided 71 million people
don't don't think that there's some good
that's happened you also don't know why
that person voted for biden or trump
because
certain people vote based off one
singular thing maybe it's the
they believe in their tax bracket or you
know this or that you know just there's
one thing that they go i'm gonna vote
based off yeah
it's not the whole package you come to
them later and be like well you know
this happened i mean if you
if you had a laundry list of things that
went wrong during the obama era
nobody wants to see that no they don't
want to see it because they just go it
was our first black president
yeah it was great for the country but
it's like you [ __ ] up you really delve
into politics to the point where you
actually know
what's really going on and i venture to
say that most people don't
in a casual conversation with people you
don't know
and you know i know you don't know
because when you got that ballot in the
mail
you didn't know who the [ __ ] 90 of the
people on this thing was okay
don't tell me you knew who like what
we're voting on the 26th district such
as 20 seconds you don't know who that
person is yeah so i was i didn't even
i just left it blank because i was like
i don't know this judge
yeah like how do i know who to vote for
this person or not you know it's just
like
all right do i want to do i want kanye
do i want you know
you know you just you that's the one you
were like this is what this is about but
like
i want to know the six thousand people
that voted for kanye yeah
you had six thousand thousand all right
but then they had a more vice president
i saw it wasn't even president it was
like vice president
obama either way six thousand people you
got six thousand people
that's what's wrong that's not good
that's i mean it's not good
those aren't good are those the dummies
or is it the 71 million people that
voted for trump
like well you gotta understand people
like she said people
harambe who [ __ ] dude like like i
totally understand if you're a person
that all you care about is your money
and your family and your in your and
you're like sixty thousand votes
yes six wait how was he able to get on
because i thought you had there's like
these things yeah literally
anyone could run for president thinking
yeah yeah anyone can run for president
you follow you
what are the requirements you file the
application apparently yeah you have to
get
whatever it is a certain number of
signatures or something i don't know
what it is
look that [ __ ] up you know what i mean
maybe i shouldn't even like i said
everybody could uh i believe anybody
could because if he if he can run for it
i would assume everybody can yeah
didn't the rock say there's certain
there's certain um
i think there's certain qualifications
you have yeah like your age your
citizenship oh got it i think you have
to be 45 or whatever
45 and above here we go 35 years of age
35 okay
they have remained the same since blah
blah blah as directed by the
constitution president kennedy must be a
natural-born citizen in the united
states resident 14 years 35 years of age
and then there so what i'm saying is
yeah that
it doesn't say it doesn't say like but
you have to
you know be a senator for eight years or
you have to you should though
but no no that's but that's just uh uh
assumed
that's not a law no trump already proved
that
yeah even even ronald reagan but he at
least was the governor of california
yeah he's just
yeah he's the governor so so it's like
so this would
you know anybody i come up for president
did roseanne barr run for president one
year
yeah i think she did yeah yeah put her
stuff in the middle
like the green party or something
independent the problem is it just
becomes a popularity vote like the nba
all-star game because like yeah i mean
you're like come on
every year
yeah she has 70 000 votes i think she
got more than
kanye well it just shows that that
that's not a lot of votes
yeah yeah you just proved that if those
you know how much money you have to have
to to run a campaign oh it's got to be
so much money
my god stupid rich but you know what
they haven't
they haven't um there needs to be reform
for that campaign finance reform they're
[ __ ] because
the world's different now like you all
you need is the internet
yeah you know so like before they they
needed a bunch of money they had a
certain amount of money because it was
like you had to get on a train or ride a
train around the country you had to buy
billboards you had to do all this stuff
but
how much now is just you know internet
yeah yeah everything is on amazon
that's why i see celebrity endorsements
because they know the celebrity's gonna
post following that didn't get out of
hell
that's why they're paying off
celebrities